Do you guys remember the Tesla roadster?
Not the classic version but the new one that
Elon announced in 2017.
The new roadster was supposed to have it all,
a 1.9 second 0 to 60, a top speed of 250 mph,
and a range of 620 miles.
Coming it at a starting price of $200,000,
the first roadsters were expected to be delivered
in 2020.
But clearly, that didn’t happen.
And now, it seems like roadsters won’t be
hitting the road till at least 2023.
So, what in the world happened to the Tesla
roadster?
Taking a look at the timeline of Roadster
delays, it’s actually not too exciting.
The timeline mostly consists of Tesla not
giving any updates and then delaying the car
right before it was supposed to come out.
The most recent update we got was in January
of 2021 when Elon tweeted that engineering
would be finished by the end of 2021, and
that production would begin in 2022.
Given that roadster prototypes apparently
hit all of their promised numbers years ago,
what’s the big hold up?
Well, likely the biggest obstacle that they
didn’t expect to face when announcing the
roadster was a near death experience.
Around the time the roadster was initially
announced, the model 3 was finally hitting
the market.
In July of 2017, the first 30 model 3 production
vehicles were delivered, and Tesla had a small
celebration event.
Ironically though, there wasn’t too much
to celebrate as Elon as well as the Tesla
employees knew that ramping up production
of the model 3 was going to be a nightmare.
You see, the first 30 model 3 vehicles were
mostly built by hand and Tesla was yet to
employ their massive automated assembly line.
Tesla knew that ramping up automated production
was going to be rather challenging, but they
didn’t expect it to nearly wipe them out.
When Tesla started production, issues would
spring up instantly.
The robots kept misaligning parts of the car,
the software kept crashing, and the worst
part was that no one really knew why.
Tesla had spent over a billion dollars building
the Gigafactory, but it looked like the factory
was a lemon.
Hundreds of quote on quote under performing
employees would be fired and the remaining
ones would be pushed extremely hard to meet
production numbers.
Even with this intense pressure though, Tesla
was nowhere near their 5000 cars a week production
goal.
Every week, Tesla didn’t meet production
numbers, they were burning loads of money,
and at one point, Tesla was within single
digit weeks of dying.
The company would eventually figure it out,
and the answer was to simply use less automation.
But reaching production numbers was just the
first of their worries.
Once the cars were manufactured, they actually
had to be delivered, and the problem was that
each delivery was built to order.
Generally, when you buy a car, you just go
to the closest dealer and pick out a car from
their lot.
With Tesla though, everyone custom builds
their cars online.
There are only a limited number of options,
but given the relatively low volume of cars
Tesla was building, it was especially hard
to come up with an efficient delivery plan
which led them to losing even more money.
Considering this massive debacle Tesla experienced,
it’s not hard to see why the roadster would
be the last thing on their list.
It should be noted that even if Tesla didn’t
experience the model 3 production nightmare,
the roadster would still be last priority.
Here’s the thing, the roadster targets an
extremely niche market and it's unlikely that
Tesla will crack the six figures and maybe
even the 5 figures in terms of sales.
So, it makes little sense for them to devote
much effort into the roadster.
This is especially true when you consider
that Tesla still has lots of room to grow
within their fundamental business itself.
Just last year, they started production of
the Model Y and looking forward, they want
to start cyber truck production by the end
of this year.
And the Austin Gigafactory where the cybertruck
is supposed to be produced is still under
construction itself.
It’s also likely that Tesla would prefer
to avoid a production nightmare when it comes
to the cybertruck and their new gigafactories.
Evidently, there’s plenty of things to focus
on in their primary business itself.
So, the roadster has never been a priority
and likely won't be one moving forward either.
The roadster is not only a low priority, but
it also comes along with a massive price tag
in terms of research and development.
Just think about it, the roadster is supposed
to have a sub 2 0 to 60, a 620 mile range,
and it’s of course supposed to be fully
electric.
Developing something like this would no doubt
cost tens if not hundreds of millions of dollars.
For a company like Tesla that's really just
breaking even at this point, such an expense
is not negligible by any means.
Moreover, this money could be spent in other
sectors which would be much more beneficial
for Tesla.
For instance, they could use the money to
make the austin gigafactory bigger and produce
more cars.
Or they could use the money for self driving
R&D which could accelerate Tesla’s vision
of creating robotaxis.
Now, money spent on roadster R&D isn’t a
waste per se.
It’s common to develop new technology on
flagship experimental vehicles, and then slowly
bring down that technology to lower tiers
of vehicles.
With the roadster, Tesla has to develop more
powerful motors and higher density batteries,
and these technologies could definitely be
brought down to the model s and x and even
the 3 and y eventually.
But, though having a model 3 with a range
of 1000 miles or something like that would
be insane, would tripling the range of a model
3 really triple the sales of the model 3.
Not really.
So, Tesla isn’t really in any rush to develop
this advanced technology and bring it down
to their lower models.
But wait a minute, didn’t Tesla reveal that
they already have working prototypes that
can hit all of the specs they outlined?
In that case, most of the R&D is already completed
right?
Well, that only indicates that Tesla has completed
tech based R&D not cost based R&D.
Not only is Tesla promising specs that destroy
Bugattis, but Tesla is promising to slash
the price over 10 fold.
It’s very possible that Tesla figured out
how to achieve the Roadster’s specs years
ago, but the problem is that it cost $5 or
$6 million to produce.
With scale, maybe they can bring it down to
$1 to $2 million, but that’s still a far
ways off from $200,000 a car.
So, the engineering challenge holding back
Tesla may very well be a cost based one as
opposed to a tech based one.
Until now, we’ve discussed a bunch of financial
and technical challenges in bringing the roadster
to market, but I don’t think the main reason
has anything to do with objective obstacles.
Rather, I think the main reason the roadster
has yet to hit the roads is because it's a
marketing tool more than anything.
The roadster isn’t built to generate profit
or reduce costs or advance Tesla’s technology.
No, the roadster is built for one reason and
one reason only which is building clout for
Tesla.
Since the original roadster, Tesla has focused
on growing organic interest by showcasing
how electric cars could be cool.
In the early 2000s, electric cars were seen
as slow, boring, and unreliable.
Tesla created the original roadster to disprove
that notion.
Using the profits generated by the sports
car, Tesla created the luxury model s and
x.
And using the profits generated by the luxury
models, Tesla created everyday people models
which are the 3 and y.
But at this point, there’s no longer a need
to generate hype for electric vehicles and
especially for Teslas.
Right now, Tesla is facing a supply problem
not a demand problem as they have way more
demand than they can handle.
Tesla didn’t exactly expect this.
Sure, they expected the model 3 and y to sell
better than any previous model, but the massive
influx of hype following the announcement
of the Cybertruck throughout 2020 was unprecedented.
Tesla no longer needed an extreme sports car
that showed that electric cars were cool.
The truth was that most Tesla owners didn’t
actually buy a Tesla because it's electric.
They actually bought a Tesla because it carries
a certain social status and it had a super
cool feature which is of course self driving.
The electric aspect of Teslas were simply
a side benefit that made tesla owners feel
better about themselves.
More times than not though, the electric aspect
of teslas were not what pushed customers to
actually buy a Tesla.
Basically everyone understands that electric
cars are the future.
Sure, there’s some disagreement on when
EVs will take over, but nearly everyone agrees
that it's inevitable.
So, at this point, Tesla’s primary marketing
goal is no longer to convince people to go
electric, but rather to go Tesla.
And the best way to accomplish this is to
build off of their strengths which is their
brand image and their autonomous features.
Considering this shift in market sentiment,
the roadster no longer plays a critical marketing
role in convincing customers to go electric
and buy a tesla.
And so, there’s no rush in bringing the
Roadster to market.
When will the roadster actually come out then?
Well, in the 2020 q2 earnings call, Elon Musk
suggested that the roadster would be built
in the Fremont factory in California.
The Fremont factory is Tesla’s primary production
plant right now though, so I don’t think
Tesla will want to devote Fremont’s production
capacity to the Roadster till their total
total production output is much higher.
Fortunately, the upcoming gigafactories in
Berlin and Austin are expected to be completed
by the end of 2021.
If this is the case, they should be able to
ramp up production throughout the first half
of 2022 which would heavily alleviate the
pressure on the Fremont factory.
And at that point, Tesla could start producing
the roadster at the Fremont factory which
would mean that the first deliveries would
take place in the second half of 2022.
There’s almost always delays though, so
a more conservative estimate would be the
first half of 2023.
So, there’s still about 2 years till we
see roadsters being delivered, but it does
seem like it’s finally going to happen.
Why do you guys think the roadster has been
pushed back so much?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you’re excited to see
the roadster finally come out.
And of course, consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.